malgré un début difficile et des
échanges tendus entre les membres de la
convention citoyenne pour le climat et
le président de la république ces
derniers mois 65 propositions ont
finalement été sélectionné plusieurs
volets sont abordés parmi eux la
réglementation de la publicité sur les
produits polluants
l'interdiction de la vente de véhicules
qui dépassent un certain seuil de co2 la
limitation des vols internes ou encore
la création d'un délit d' écocide pour
les entreprises concernées
de nombreuses propositions prévoit
d'infliger des amendes importantes afin
de faire respecter ces mesures à des
contraintes qui met l'exécutif dans une
position délicate
un jeu d'équilibriste pour emmanuel
macron qui veut respecter ses
engagements mais en même temps éviter de
fragiliser des secteurs de l'économie
déjà mis à mal par la pandémie
l'exécutif a donc prévenu certaines
mesures ne seraient pas pour tout de
suite comme la fiscalité sur l'aérien
est député écologiste et ong reprochent
au gouvernement de vouloir alléger les
mesures contraignantes
l'ambition fixée par l'exécutif à savoir
la réduction de moins de 40 % des
émissions de gaz à effet de serre d'ici
à 2030 semble complètement irréalisable
de nombreuses dispositions sont juste là
pour dire que l'état va écrire une autre
loi dans deux ou trois ans pour prendre
réellement des mesures on reporte
toujours à plus tard les propositions
structurantes et contraignantes les
mesures emblématiques qui changerait
réellement la donne pour le climat sont
presque toutes éludée si les députés
écologistes se sont mitigés barbara
pompili ministre de la transition
écologique attendu au tournant
se réjouit de ce projet il nous reste
beaucoup de chemin à faire mais nous
sommes sur les rails pour respecter nos
engagements dans la période sombre que
nous traversons c'est une vraie note
d'espoir et ça doit nous encourager à
aller plus loin nos efforts payent le
texte passera au conseil des ministres
aujourd'hui et sera finalement examinée
à l'assemblée nationale fin mars